foreign
[Music]
so for those watching on YouTube I'm
recording the speed run really late so
I'm going to do a slightly shorter game
and Analysis but obviously the plan is
for the quality to still be as high as
it normally is
so we're gonna play ten plus zero now
we're 2051 so obviously the moves
themselves are going to be made more
quickly I'm going to have a little bit
less time for explanation during the
game but we'll have plenty after the
game we get the white pieces let's go
with one E4
we're playing Caleb Miller from England
2030. okay we haven't actually faced E5
in a very long time and we've been
carrying out two openings obviously the
Vienna is one of them the four night
Scotch is the other let's see how the
fortnite scotch uh holds up at this
pretty high level so first we develop
all of our Knights
and after Knight F6 we strike in the
center with D4 we've had great success
with this opening so far and let's see
what the higher rated peeps can show us
here now it's pretty amazing we have not
even once faced the main line here which
is e takes D4 Knight takes D4 and then
Bishop B4 we faced Edie and the Knight
takes D4 we faced I think D6 this guy
plays a pretty decent sideline Bishop to
B4 this is an okay move white is
slightly better in this line and we
should respond not by playing de which
allows Knight takes E4 but by pushing D5
and grabbing some space I play like this
sometimes with black because it's
basically a line that forces white to
close up the center and so it gives
black chances to play for a win but from
a spatial perspective black is obviously
worse okay so again we don't want to
play Knight takes C5 here because of
Knight takes E4 with pressure on the C3
Knight so instead we develop our Bishop
and protect the D3 Pawn taking the sting
out of Knight takes E4
and of course we're also not afraid of
Bishop takes Knight because yes the pawn
structure is going to be damaged but in
return we get the bishop pair and we
also get the possibility of supporting
our center with C4
okay so here we can Castle obviously we
can also play the move H3 in order to
limit the development of this bishop but
typically Bishop G4 is not particularly
worrying in this type of position
because black is rather passive so in
response to Bishop G4 we could respond
with H3
chase the bishop back and we could even
play G4 okay so our opponent plays this
a little bit differently yeah he knows
what he's doing this is actually the
right setup for Black with the Knight
coming to G6 so again it's a closed
Center position and we've had this type
of position all quite a few times
already in the speedrun and one of the
key takeaways is that when you have a
closed Center position the value of each
individual move is greatly diminished
you can do a lot of different things in
a lot of different orders but the bottom
line is that you have to have the right
setup and the right General plan so
there's less of an emphasis on each move
individually and more so on on what it
is that you're aiming for in general
so we're going to start by playing H3
now I'd like to prevent the development
of this bishop
other good moves that would improve our
position are definitely C4 which I'd
like to play right now and just to
reinforce the D5 Pawn maybe insinuating
that we want to play C5 one day our
opponent is playing this very
confidently I have to give a lot of
credit so we're just going to continue
developing our pieces normally Bishop G5
is a move which would catch a lot of
people's eye but then black will play H6
and TR and uh chase our Bishop away
anyway so let's just start with Bishop
to E3
and now we've completed our development
and we can start operating on the side
of the board where we have an advantage
which is of course the king side because
on the queen side we're never going to
be able to play C5 on the king side we
have more pieces assembled and we've got
several interesting types of ideas so
I'm going to try to carry out a plan
which I'll be doing rather quickly
during the game then after the game I'll
break it down step by step assuming that
it works okay we start with King H2 the
idea of this move is both prophylactic
and aggressive the prophylactic
component is actually to prepare a
response to Knight H5 which is a rather
nasty idea in this type of position
now the night is coming to F4 so the
move that we want to play is G3 but we
would not have been able to play this
move were it not for the placement of
this King we would have walked into
Bishop takes H3 so this is a rather
common defensive idea now why else did
our opponent play Knight H5 well
presumably he's thinking about going F5
but tactically that move fails if black
plays F5 I think we take on F5 black
takes back with the bishop we take again
on F5 and after The Rook takes are none
of my oh my God I cannot draw arrows
right now F5 takes takes takes takes
and then we play G4 at the end of the
line forking The Rook in the night
the drawback of putting the Knight on H5
and just chilling there is that our
Queen is x-raying the Knight so on the
next move we could move this Knight off
of F3 which is something that I wanted
to do anyway because we are trying to
execute the F4 Pawn break eventually
so we could do that at some point
and Chase the Knight away from H5
because it has to go back to F6 and then
we could push F4 anyway
so we we essentially gain a Tempo
carrying out the plan that I had in mind
when playing King H2 it's entirely
possible that even if black had not
played Knight H5 we would have still
played G3 move the Knight away and
played F4 so unless black makes this
happen tactically chances are Knight H5
will merely throw oil onto the fire
so yeah F5 he takes F5 and then E4 is a
tactical possibility for black then we
just take the Knight on G6 and I think
when when all is said and done black is
going to end up a pawn down
probably that's the Lesser evil like
after F5 EF5 there's this common pattern
where black pushes E4 this kind of idea
exists in the it's an old line in the
Marshall in the Roy Lopez it's not a
good line but but but this type of idea
exists that we just take the Knight
there and H7 hangs and once black takes
our Bishop then we can just recapture on
D3 so I don't think black will be able
to restore uh material equality there so
already black is kind of at a loss like
I don't know what black should do if you
look at the other side of the board it
just nothing's going on there and that's
part of the reason that we put this Pawn
on C4 just to make sure that D5 is
nicely reinforced that there's no
Shenanigans like if black ever plays C6
we can essentially just ignore because
of how well protected D5 is so all of
the action is happening on the king side
we're both fighting for positioning and
territory on the king side and I think
we're winning the battle just based on
how long our opponent is spending on
this move
yeah black probably should go back to FC
I don't know what black should do here
honestly maybe Knight back to F6 some of
you might be worried about Queen E7 to
D7 attacking H3 but that is actually
nothing to worry about the Knight can
drop back to G1 in such cases
and this is another defensive idea that
is not too uncommon
uh dropping the Knight back to G1 and
later the Knight can go back to F3
an important thing to remember when you
have a a pattern like this where you've
got a knight on G1 that's holding upon
let's say on H3 you might look at that
and say well this is very passive right
the Knight on G1 is tied down to the
protection of the Pawn on H3 if that's
true but look at it from the other side
the queen on D7 is also tied down to
attacking the pawn in H3 so as long as
the Knight is on G1 the queen is on D7
and both pieces are rather passive but
the moment the queen moves away from D7
the Knight is free to go so it's almost
a two-sided Arrangement where neither
side benefits but we're more than happy
to spend our nights okay that is that's
a funny phrase because you can like
spend your night doing something but use
our Knight to protect the H3 pawn and
keep Lex Queen at Bay he moves the
Knight back to F6 okay this allows us to
continue carrying out our plan
now we need to be careful because if we
play Knight D2 then actually we walk
into Queen to D7 and in that position we
can play G4 in fact we would have to
play G4 but the drawback of pushing G4
in this position is that the F4 square
is severely weakened and then we will
never really be able to push F4 as we
wanted to so I think a very interesting
idea here is actually to play Knight G1
preemptively with a the idea of
protecting H3 and B the idea of
preparing F4 now we're not ready to play
F4 yet okay our opponent would not have
seen Queen D7 because he basically
pre-moved this
now just because you make a move with
one intention doesn't mean that you need
to close your eyes and blindly follow
through on it you need to understand how
your opponent's move has impacted your
plan and perhaps you have new plans that
are possible based on what he did I
think that's the case here F4 has a has
a very severe tactical flaw if you play
well there's certain openings where this
kind of thing happens e takes F4 G takes
F4 black can Counter-Strike in the
center with F5 and notice that the
bishop on E3 is x-rayed by the queen so
e takes F5 there leads to a bunch of
tactics which don't look too appetizing
for us because our King ends up very
weak at the end of the line so how do we
fix that well we can play Knight E2 as
some people are suggesting but the fix
isn't to apply more Defenders on the F4
Square the fix is potentially to protect
this bishop in order to take the sting
out of the later move at five but we we
aren't in time for that because if we
play Queen td2 then black swings the
Knight over to C5 and then F4 doesn't
work for for a different reason there
black takes on F4 and the E4 Pawn is
hanging so I think we actually need to
switch our plan a little bit and for the
time being to abandon the prospect of f4
and to go a little bit differently on
the king side I think that we should
consider the move H4
and you might be like well this comes
out of nowhere well it doesn't really
come out of nowhere because the pot on
G3 is supporting the the advance of the
H Pawn now some of you might worry about
the sack on H4 there you just have to
calculate a little bit Knight H4 GH4
Queen takes H4 check we simply Slide the
king over to G2 and notice the defensive
role that the Knight on G1 plays once
the knight in that position moves away
from D7 black will not be threatening
the very powerful check on H3 because
the Knight on G1 is securing that square
what do I like about the move H4 well
there's the straightforward idea of
pushing H5 and knocking this Knight into
like Oblivion on h8 then there's the
nice byproduct of the fact that you know
now our Knight can move away from G1 and
we no longer have to worry about the
weak Pawn we still have to worry about
you know Queen getting to H3 but it no
longer comes with a capture we get the
G5 Square potentially as a as a semi
Outpost for our Bishop in certain cases
so I just think this is a healthy
positional move and we're not
necessarily abandoning the idea of
playing F4 although it becomes a lot
less likely if our Pawn is on H5 because
once we push H5 pushing F4 is just gonna
severely weaken our King and we would
only do that if the circumstances were
just right Knight C5 our opponent is
playing great
okay
so I think that we should consider
pushing H5
we can also yeah let's start with H5 and
then we'll think
I don't think this move can possibly
hurt
okay
so I think net h8 is basically forced
and then I'm actually thinking about
what we what what we should do afterward
Knight F4
okay I will admit I completely missed
this move
does it work
let me calculate takes
check here
six
Bishop C5
Bishop G4
it should be two
oh yes oh it's Queen G5 track so that's
a draw huh
incredible move I think it works
tactically but it doesn't win the game
or anything we don't have to take the
Knight we can also take care first maybe
that is the solution to our woes to take
on C5 first
huh
I need to think for a little longer here
and they don't make these two thousands
like they used to okay they're they're
there
I think we should play Bishop C5
actually
okay let's go Bishop C5 now Queen H4 is
not Checkmate because the pawn protects
that square
now there's a very specific reason I I
wanted to take there first now I think
we can play GF
now I think we can get away with GF
although it is very close
this is like move for move you have to
calculate this right or you lose kind of
territory
okay I think
I think that we can take the Knight
you can cheat two
and now the idea is Queen F3 now this is
a terrifying move to play I'm terrified
here
I'm terrified here there might be some
some tactical detail that I'm missing
which wins the game I don't
dispute that I mean that's entirely
possible but I don't see one
and I think move for a move we might be
fine here
and this has been a very very tough run
the last couple of games in the speedrun
now there's there's a ton of of
calculational details that stand behind
this these these decisions that I just
made one of them is that if black plays
Bishop G4 right now there's Queen takes
pawn and Bishop H3 looks like it wins
the queen but no our Knight comes around
takes the bishop and simultaneously
protects the queen if black tries to
give Perpetual check with a queen G5
check King H2 and then go back to H4
that very same Knight can block the
check from that very same square Knight
H3 and if black develops the bishop the
queen drops back to G2 the line goes on
but I think we emerge up a piece so I'm
just not seeing The Knockout blow here
of course it's a different question like
okay but wow F5 okay
five no this doesn't look that scary to
me actually because I think we can just
take the pawn
I think we can just take the pawn
I mean it's still it's still very very
scary in general
but I think we might be on the way to
consolidating here
okay so what do we do there's Queen H3
but then Queen G5 check is is very nasty
no I think we have to take
we also could have played Rook a to E1
but I like the prospect of trading the
Bishops obviously the more pieces we
trade here the less powerful the attack
on the other hand training the Bishops
has a negative which is that it allows
the Rope to get into the attack
and it things get pretty scary I think
that it's worth biting the bullet here
now Rook G5 Checkmate is the threat so
let's bring our night out in order to
defend the G5 Square I think that's an
only move like allowing oh we we did
have Rook F to E1 Rook G5 and then
ducking away on F1 but there the problem
with that was this move Queen H2 at the
end of the line that looked scary as
well I think that we should King is like
the captain of the Titanic we have to
sink you know we have to die with the
ship here
and and I want to keep the King on G2 as
long as possible now it's surrounded by
a lot of its own pieces so we've got
friendly forces all around the king side
The Rook protects the Knight the Knight
defends G5 tactics let's calculate here
Shack that doesn't oh Queen cheating no
it doesn't work
Rook G1 comes to mind
open up an Escape Route for the king
Rook E1 also comes to mind I'm gonna go
Rook E1 I think for the first time in
this entire game and in this entire
sequence we have the luxury of just sort
of making a you know it's just a general
improving move now you might look at
this and say well why rookie one what is
the point of this the point of this is
simply you're just getting a rook onto
an open file there's no profound idea
here I'm just trying to make
improvements to guarantee better chances
of a successful defense
okay
now we can continue improving The Rook
with the rookie six but then we're
abandoning its counterpart on H1 making
it impossible for the Knight to move
what do we do
rookie four is interesting but then G5
man let's run
uh that was a bad move actually
maybe not bad actually that wasn't that
was an interesting move King F1 it's a
safe move because we're entering time
pressure again for those watching on
YouTube because it was so late when I
started this game I started at 10 plus
zero lower counter play and this was my
idea Rook to E6 because now if black
plays G4 we can give a check on G6 and
pick up that pawn so we're defending
using tactics and you can feel that
Black's attack is starting to fizzle out
the queen and the Rook are fully stuck
on the king side suddenly black skin is
now very weak but we need to continue
playing accurately here
I'm gonna play a move completely by
intuition which is Queen to E4 I can
sense that we're very close to
delivering Checkmate to Black here
but we might need to be very accurate
huh I'm trying to figure out what we do
if black plays G4 insanely enough I
don't see forced mate but I see a very
promising idea there
suddenly we're the ones going for
checkmate
Plex sees it okay I'm gonna go for my
idea which is to give a check
and now to dive into E6 with the queen
and my idea is if black takes the Knight
that's not a check we check on C8 King
E7 rookie six mate which is a mating
pattern that you should kind of be
familiar with where like okay never mind
forget everything anything but now we're
winning
now we're winning in a variety of ways
but you have 48 seconds you're sitting
there you're trying to calculate Queen
C8 I'm gonna play Queen C8 because I'm a
professional
actually Quincy a rookie eight so it
doesn't even really matter what order
you do things we can start by giving
this check then we take on G4 and we
eliminate that pesky pawn and we win the
game now we're up a full piece we're
threatening this devastating check on G8
and so by extension we're forcing the
queen trade and once the Queens are
traded okay then we can finally breathe
we still need to play quickly but now
it's a matter of what that's another
great move by our opponent but now it's
a matter of converting in a matter of
technique we're no longer at risk of
getting Checkmate let me think for a
little bit
okay I think we can get away with this
move
let's get our Rook involved
let's get our Knight involved
check
trying to play accurately here I'm
trying not just a flag of a knight G5
wins
and now we go for the ladder mate
okay I think we just take the Rook
wow
turned out to be a really interesting
game actually despite the shortened time
control
that was uh that was nerve-wracking I
have to say definitely mistakes were
made in the Tactical phase of the game
let's take a look
the accuracy of the game I know people
like for me to check
the accuracy of the game
was
89.4 to 79.7 it's actually not not bad
but clearly some inaccuracies were made
the funny thing is I've never really
faced uh this bishop E4 line I I played
it with black just sort of casually so
I'm I'm not entirely sure what the
theoretical recommendation is with white
I know that D5 is a well reputed you
know it is a it is a decent reputation
but it's not the only move
and looking at opening Explorer
let me check chess space really quickly
since this is like the opening Speed Run
I want to make sure that I'm not
you know I I want to make sure that I'm
telling you accurate opening information
so in this line with Bishop B4 which by
the way is a very good line for black if
you are a E4 E5 player this is a line
that often slips through the cracks even
with experienced four night Scotch
players okay so I'm going to turn on
stockfish and I'm going to see what uh
the recent games can tell us
okay so apparently the best move here is
not D5 it's actually Knight takes E5 see
I didn't know that and here's how this
goes if black plays 95 de and Knight
takes E4 white has a very very powerful
move here now this is an idea that you
see in a bunch of different openings so
for example there is a sicilian line
called the pin variation which is now
out of fashion nobody plays it anymore
the pin variation goes Knight F6 Knight
C3 and Bishop B4
and the way to refute the pin variation
is to push E5 and after 94 it's the same
exact idea Queen to G4 forking the
knight in the pawn now here you have to
know some tactical details you play
Queen takes G7 and this construction is
a lot less scary than it seems I think
for newer players you might wow you're
allowing a discover check but as long as
the queen is far enough away from the
Knight there's nothing because if the
Knight moves back you just play C3 and
you block the discovery attacking the
bishop incidentally the pin variation
the only thing you have to know is this
move A3 attacking the tail of the
discovery which is I something I say
very often when you're trying to disarm
a discover check mechanism a lot of
people instinctively pile up on the
piece that's moving but often the way to
do it is to pile up on the tail of the
piece that's giving the check because
that way no matter where the Knight
moves and the Knight has no way of
delivering a check you'll be able to
take the bishop once the bishop moves
away now The Rook is poorly defended and
you can play Bishop H6 after Queen E7 I
think the best move is to do the same
thing again if you're watching on
YouTube you can pause try to figure out
the right move
and it's not B4 because then you
relinquish the attack on the night you
want to keep the spot on B2 so that
you'll be able to take the Knight the
move is actually Knight to B3 but if you
understand the theme this is an easy
move because you hit the bishop if the
bishop moves you just play BC and then
at your leisure you can play Queen takes
f8 check and win The Exchange
so that was a bit of a detour but it's
it's a common theme this this queen she
form motif very similar position
actually here it works a little bit
differently it works no worse than it
does in the pin variation because if
black takes here you can play Queen
takes G7 but as a simpler option you can
actually straight away take the bishop
the Knight is forced to move and you can
swing sorry no not there you can swing
back to G4
and basically black is in big trouble
because he's poorly developed G7 is
hanging
and black is really suffering on the
dark squares because here you have
Bishop H6
and if black plays G6 then you can just
bring the bishop out anyway I mean just
This Disaster for black
so
there's some more lines black has D5 but
then you play Queen takes G7 you can
look at the rest on your own
so that's the reason why Knight takes E5
is good here black has to play the
immediate Knight takes E4
and here things get very tactical
um actually Queen E7 is also a move here
if Knight takes E4 you still play Queen
G4 oh so this idea is actually the way
the way to play The Line Knight C3 Queen
G7 or Cafe you play this exactly like a
pin variation A3 Bishop A5
and here apparently the best line is
Knight C6 DC
now the same concept again Queen back
attacking the bishop forcing the queen
trade and at the end of the line you
play the simple and very powerful Bishop
D2 you're gonna win the night back with
interest
you're going to be a pawn up in the
resulting position actually maybe not
but you're just gonna have a better end
game in the resulting position because
in this position
computer move is H4 with the idea of
Rook H3 and Rook E3 white is better
because we have better Pawn structure
like as these doubled pawns and you can
find a nice little safe spot for your
King on F2
and you've got basically an easier Pawn
majority to mobilize on the king's side
and black has more Pawn weaknesses and
worse coordination among his pieces if
Rook ae8 by the way you can just play F3
to disarm the discovery against White's
King it's a forced line that's actually
important to know finally the main moves
for black is Queen E7 and here you lift
your queen up to D3 defending defending
95 d e Queen takes E5
finally the Smoke Clears and white is
just slightly better here Bishop D2
Castle's King side Castle Queen side
and you have basically a very nice
version of a center game almost
like if black plays D6
then you can play F3 to reinforce this
pawn and then you basically start the
king side attack with G4 and G5
so and here if black plays Bishop C3
Bishop C3 Queen E4 I think some people
might be curious
at the end of the line we pick up the
pawn on G7 with a relatively small but
very stable advantage in the end game
you have the bishop pair again you have
better Pawn structure I would be more
than happy to play this so I learned
stuff too
and the best move is actually not D5
it's Knight takes E5 but in the game we
decided to go for a close Center I think
this position is probably very close to
being equal sorry about that
I think this position is very close to
being equal and it's probably just not
not better for white I mean it's it's
not worse we have the bishop bear we
have a little bit more space but we also
have a damaged Pawn structure and black
is very well placed pieces the knights
are nicely assembled on the king side
the bishop has good prospects you know
there's this Knight H5 Knight F4 idea
whereas white just doesn't have any very
clear plans and I started understanding
that once his Knight got to G6 very
instructive moment also our opponent did
seem very comfortable as someone is
saying in the chat with like the typical
plans in this position
so H3 okay castles and C4 we were just
making some improving moves both of us I
think B6 is a very instructive move for
newer players notice how our opponent is
just preventing the idea of C5 you might
look at this table doesn't C5 blender
upon well it does currently but under
different circumstances if the E5 Pawn
were weaker we could very well play C5
and that could really be the difference
because it could open the floodgates on
the queen side so I like this move from
our opponent Bishop B3 Queen E7 is just
sort of a neutral move same with King H2
I was already preparing G3 and now the
fun begins so Knight H5 G3 again if
black plays F5 we actually have several
options here
um if you're a 1d4 player with white if
if you play The King's Indian from the
white side but also if you play from the
black side you should be familiar with
this idea
which has plagued you know countless
King's Indian players and basically what
happens is that if you have a situation
where you play F5 too early in the
king's Indian very often you allow this
very nasty idea with a knight coming to
G5 and then coming to E6 that's actually
why you sometimes see Kings Indian
players go H6 to protect that square
and in the king's Indian you often don't
want to give away your light squared
Bishop so that's why you don't want to
allow the Knight to get to E6 so
translating it to our current position
you have a lot of the same themes Knight
G5 is actually a very strong move here
because it hits the Knight on H5 and you
might find F4 to be scary but tactically
it doesn't work you just take the Knight
and threaten checkmate
and black has to go back and then you
just play EF and not only do you win a
pawn but you have this monster E6 Square
for the Knight
as well as what I had in mind initially
which was the F5
and and this idea Bishop F5 is 5 and G4
according to the engine black is
actually not worse here this is actually
not the best way to punish Black's play
Black has a very instructive idea here
sack The Exchange on F3 which is obvious
because black is no other way to save
material right if black moves the rookie
loses the Knight so Rook F3 should be
obvious to you
Queen F3 is forced and now the Rook
comes to f8 with Tempo and why does
black have sufficient compensation for
the exchange because black has this
monster monster Square for the night
second main reason is because the center
is closed so the Rooks just don't have
any active prospects a great example of
a simple exchange sack that gives the
side that sacrifices it excellent play
Queen H4 is coming you know the Knight
can jump into E2 in some cases the
rooksters don't have anything going for
them if you play A4 black can even take
the time to close the queen side with A5
and basically keep this rock confined
so the correct move here would not be G4
the correct move here would not be e
takes F5 it would actually be Knight G5
so this is uh an interesting line I'm
glad our opponent didn't play F5 he went
back to F6 which I think is a great move
somebody was asking is Knight take C5
available here so it's a tempting move
and you should always consider it in
these situations but it doesn't tell the
whole story you can't just stop
calculating here and say oh I'm up a
pawn because you've given black this
monster Knight on E5 and you're given
black just like a insane initiative on
the king side Knight G4 check is very
strong here by the way because it Roots
the bishop out and the queen is now out
of commission this is a threat White's
hole position starts to crumble here so
so Knight takes C5 is is good a good
tactical eye but it it gives black just
a massive initiative on the king side
we go Knight G1 our opponent goes Knight
D7 which is another great move by the
way the Knight is transferred over to C5
as it often is in the king's Indian so
let's get to the fun part of the game we
played H4 Knight c5h5 Knight F4 best
move for our opponent massive Kudos
because I came to the assumption that
Knight h8 was first now I don't think
that h8 is a bad move
I I don't think that h8 is a bad move at
all
um I think that
I think that Knight h8 is the
straightforward move but black can
combine this with F5 and I don't think
black is worse here now I was gonna play
something like F3 and try to go G4 and
weave uh upon net around the king side
but blackened beat us to the punch with
F5 and likely we're gonna get some sort
of Liquidation on the F5 Square we're
gonna get this position which I really
don't think is worse for black I would
actually go so far as to say that
Black's position is preferable here
because our pawns are bad the king is is
kind of Airy and this Knight can come
around to F7 and then later to G5 and
put pressure on this backward Pawn on F3
so
yeah so this entire type of position
just isn't that good for white it's like
a king's Indian where you can't attack
on the queen side because of the
crippled Pawn structure a very
instructive to see how black how
comfortable black is in positions where
white might have a space Advantage but
white is no good active plans on the
queen side
so our opponent goes here now the reason
I played Bishop C5 the reason I didn't
go here is because after Queen H4 check
King G2 e takes F4 this bishop is
attacked and if we take on C5 now then
black has Perpetual check this is
actually something I missed initially
this check on G5 is very easy it's easy
to forget about it why is it so good
because you can't run away you get
checkmated you have to go back to the H
file and black just keeps checking you
obviously blocking with the Knight is
just absurd here because this square is
defended twice
so you get a draw so what I decided was
to take on C5 first
BC now to take on F4
and in this position
if black plays EF which is exactly what
happened the bishop is no longer hanging
I've essentially snucked this move in
which gives me this extra Tempo that I
can now use to bring my queen into the
defense
the position apparently is still equal
according to the engine black missed a
very important attacking idea here I
think F5 was the biggest culprit I think
this is very close to being the decisive
mistake because it offers the bishop
trade and our opponent's idea was
correct conceptually conceptually the
right attacking plan is to get this Rook
involved because without the Rook black
cannot finish the King again Bishop G4
Queen takes F4 is a very important
tactical detail even though the Queens
are in an x-ray there is no Discovery
because if Knight takes H3 notice the
defensive power of this Knight on G1
if black checks here and then checks
again we have Knight H3
and again this is the presence of the
queen on F3 Bishop G4 this had to be
calculated Queen back to G2 and white
consolidates F3 we have Queen G3 and
we're chilling Queen takes H5 Rook G1
and white black is forced to trade on H3
because of the maid thread on G7
hopefully this line makes sense this is
a very important line
so you just you know these situations
just have to calculate there's just no
way around it by the way if black starts
with Bishop G4 you could even go Knight
H3 anyway and counter-attack the Queen
so in any case
the correct idea was to go rookie it to
basically do the same thing except
without trading the Bishops because the
bishop is a very important attacking
asset the idea is to lift The Rook to G5
and deliver Checkmate white has to run
away so if you're watching on YouTube
see if you can figure out how to
evacuate the king from G2 and I I had
carried this idea out in the actual game
so this should be familiar too what
should white do here which just leads to
like a very complex position
actually this is a mistake
no Knight H3 is wrong because it walks
into this move
remember that with a king on H2 you
could drop the queen back to G2 here you
lose the Knight on H3 with me
rookie one is a mistake because here
after you evacuate and black plays Rook
G5 it's a very instructive scenario you
can't go here because you get pinned and
so the king is kind of just stuck on F1
where it's gonna be like massacred by
all these moves the correct move is Rook
F to C1
because
take this position
here you need to find another engine
move so let's compare this position yeah
this position in this position
here The Rook is on C1
and here The Rook is on E1
the correct move here is E5
and I'll explain the idea in a second if
you play E5 with the Rook on E1 black
plays Bishop G4
now let's transition The Rook to C1
here after E5 Bishop G4 you have Queen
takes F4
now you might say well why does this not
work with the Rook on E1 well because
after Rook fe1
if you do the same thing with the Rook
on E1 after Queen takes F4 there is an
insane attack
oh this is beautiful
look at this in this position black to
play and win who can find the move
and there you will see why you actually
need the Rook on C1 this is unbelievably
deep
Bishop E2 check is correct but it's not
the end of the line
because well it is the end of the line
Bishop P2 check wins the game if white
takes with any of the three pieces I
highlighted in Orange you lose the queen
white must take with a knife but Queen
H3 is Checkmate now do you see how the
Rook anyone hurts white were The Rook to
be on C1 you would have the Escape
Square King he won
this is tactical chess edits at its
finest so if we do the same thing here
white can play Knight E2 check Queen H3
is no longer made and queen H1 this is
the craziest thing actually loses for
black because the Knight can return to
G1 and open up a different Escape store
for the king and the reason we put the
Rook on C1 and not on B1
is because honestly one of the most
beautiful like Concepts I've seen in a
while is because with the Rook on B1
at the end of this line you lose the
exchange on B1 whereas with the Rook on
C1 the queen is defending it Queen is
defending
the C1 Square
absolute insane moment but hopefully you
followed it I would there is no way I
would see any of that King E2 and the
queen protects the Rook white wins the
game and that is the simple reason why
white has to evacuate with Rook fc1 of
course the takeaway if you're watching
this and you're a newer player like WTF
is this concept of moving The Rook away
and then dashing away with the king
that's kind of the general takeaway the
specific takeaway is that chess is a
crazy game and this is why tactics are
so complicated because everything boils
down to these like minute tactical
details that are six or seven moves into
the variation
you know which is why your calculation
has to be so well developed a kind of a
grand master tactical level
this would be a GM level problem this
would be something I'd get from my coach
he would give me an hour and he would
say choose between rookie one Rook C1
and rugby one right this would be a
perfect example A lot of people ask me
like what what do Grandmasters solve
like this would be a good example of
that right I'd have like 30 minutes and
I'd have to choose between these three
moves so absolute absolute insanity and
you don't necessarily learn anything
from this analysis I think it's just
cool right some some things can just be
appreciated you don't have to learn from
every single variation that you look at
it's okay to just have fun and enjoy
something and enjoy you know an engine
line from time to time
five right idea wrong execution because
once the Bishops are traded and we go
Knight H3 there's no Bishop G4 so
although black is able to pick up
another Pawn at this point Black's
attack starts to fizzle out because
there's just no entry points the Knight
is protecting G5 the queen is protecting
G4 that's it if black plays G5 there's
Knight takes F4 which is another really
sexy tactic by the way that I had to see
because otherwise G4 comes really really
fast
and that's it because okay obviously the
queen is hanging Queen takes out four
the simplest is just to take the queen
and then to take the rook and we're up
or upper Rook so there's not much the
black can do he tried to get the second
Rook involved but at the end of the day
like we evacuated our King we smashed
our Rook into E6 this is a really nice
move by the way using indirect defense
right you see an idea that starts to
panic you know a lot of people I think
newer players especially would be very
tempted by a move like this in time
pressure and would blunder the Knight
away or or maybe would move the Knight
away and blunder The Rook remember that
you have such a thing as indirect
defense the move G5 weakens the king
severely that's the first thing that I
see when I look at this move and so this
idea of rookie six it comes to me
because I understand that now the G6
square is accessible potentially to a
rook and it's accessible with check
Rook F7 Queen E4 the rest of the game is
very straightforward I had to see this
idea though this is actually an only
move according to the engine this is an
only winning move Queen A6 with the idea
of delivering this checkmate
so this is just something that I had to
see there's no other moves because the
Knight is hanging and again you can't
move the Knight because you lose the
Rook
so that was the the negative of dropping
the king back is that the defense of the
Rook has been relinquished
but after Queen E6 rookie five jack here
Queen G4 and the game is over we win the
ninth and the rest of the game is pretty
straightforward Queen C8 was an
unnecessary finesse uh the best move
according to the engine was actually to
play Rook takes G4 as a matter of fact
this was the best move because in this
position we are directly contact making
contact with the H6 Pawn as opposed to
playing Queen's hd4 Where You Hear The
Rook is on G4 in that line The Rook is
on H4 another subtlety this is a
slightly inferior version it's still
winning technically because black will
pick up some pawns on the queen side but
as you saw in the game what I did with
my last seconds is basically first I got
my king involved this is a very
important detail The Rook is protected
I got my Rook involved and I just like
went after him like once the Knight gets
into the game the black king is toast I
mean look at all these threats and black
can can pick up a bunch of puns but but
the king is going to get massacred and
black will lose more material and that's
how the game ended I mean my opponent
could have kept resisting with King to
E8 I would have probably just taken the
pawn and just converted this position
kind of a boring fashion instead he
helped me out a little bit by giving up
the Rook Knight G5 hitting the Rook
obviously uh King E8 ig5 allows Rook to
E7 so remember this if you're defending
blocking a check with the piece that is
being targeted in a discovery that's
very often forgotten about by players
who just assumed oh this loses The Rook
like no you can actually use the piece
that's getting attacked to block the
check
and often you need to leave a certain
Square open for that piece
okay and that finished the game king
7.95 and the rest is history wow so
reduce time control but I still think we
got a super interesting game I learned a
lot from the opening in the sense that
D5 I thought was automatic it's not this
actually could be considered a serious
inaccuracy so Knight takes E5 for
opening Andes is the move
and then of course very very well played
by my opponent in the first stage of the
game showing us how difficult these
positions are to play it's not about the
space Advantage it's about who has the
easier plan and in this case the side
wasn't easier plan as black with this F7
F5 idea
so that's that we had some nice
prophylactic ideas with G3
we dropped our Knight back to G1 try to
execute the F4 move but that didn't work
just really quickly takes takes F5 of
course was the the reason that we didn't
that we didn't go F4
the ability to switch plans at a
moment's notice is something that I
applied here with H4 then again kudos to
our opponent for Knight F4 and then
incredible complications relying on our
calculation is obviously indispensable
at this level that's what a lot of these
games just come down to it's just pure
calculation tactics and that's the hard
truth of hitting 2000 plus just that
your positional knowledge is great it
helps you get good positions but a lot
of games are just whether you like it or
not going to boil down to your ability
to detect tactical finesse which is why
I keep hammering him home the importance
of puzzle solving constantly and
developing robust pattern recognition
ability to spot details
well hope you enjoyed that game guys I'm
gonna hit the sack because I want to do
title Tuesday I'll see you tomorrow bye
foreign
[Music]